i'm doing all these jokes about playing
wolverine at universal studios and i'm
looking down in between jokes and she
had said something earlier that was a
little uh off color and and just
annoying and drunk and obnoxious and i
said she at one point she goes usually
it's kim gave me a kiss and i was like
should i let her give me a kiss and
everyone's like yeah so i went over
there and she like licked the side of my
face and then i made some you know dumb
joke about being like oh man i don't
know you could get hpv and herpes and
[ __ ] blah blah and one you know lick
how many licks does it take to get to
the top of cougarmouth or something i
said i just see my peripheral vision
just this
and then i just see that i just went
like that
the base of the wine glass hits my palm
and it's just sweaty enough and hot
whatever to wear like part of the glass
like
hit and stuck almost in the webbing of
my hand to where all i had to do was
just wrap around the base of the glass
kid you not and then i slowly turn to my
hand and i go
and everybody goes nuts and i walked
over and i set it down on her table and
i said i told you i'm wolverine [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with me